lies in the conversation what should we
talk about we kids are you playing Halo
no no you just have that I mean I played
like the og ones but I don't there's no
video game that is currently satisfying
my game boner right now okay your game
bone game boner game boners yes so you
have a game boner
there's just no this song is fluffing it
it's like a morning game boner
so you it's natural it's a great t-shirt
morning game boner I'm sorry I just
kicked your [ __ ] right in that's what
happened this we're good I gotta say I
am it we'll do it on a t-shirt no we'll
have like a royalties conversation yeah
no morning game boner we got it we can't
just skip on there that's a great
morning game that's great dude I'm gonna
wake up play games and when Alena gives
me [ __ ] I'll be like hey hey hey let me
piss it out okay it's gonna go away
I just need like 30 45 minutes yes cold
shower
yeah cold shower man what does this
become
oh so anyway yeah love video game you
don't look for tonight then you know
what I thought it was cool for a second
that I played it and I first you can't
do it Silas loves it and still you know
every other day yeah with the hammy you
saw a casual amar he's playing fortnight
with the hammy
he's a user you're like a social
fortnight player you think you think
Kendrick is in his life never Lena I'm
playing for a night with the home he
doesn't even sound so morning game yeah
morning game boner man don't worry about
it bro sorry sorry sorry
just messing up your studio okay no bro
uh so you don't focus for tonight no one
listened to the podcast folks before
tonight either I have a fortnight line
that I've wrapped in my in a song I did
yeah cuz it was fun I thought it'd be
funny yeah we're like did you really
just mention fortnight I got upset and I
was like man yeah I guess so what was
the line I don't play no games let's be
in fortnightly it's like yeah it could
have been I don't play no games as we
talk in Red Dead I don't play no games
as we're talking Metal Gear Solid I
don't play no games like yeah could have
been anything and I was just like oh
this is poppin right now so he was
dropped and in there
dropped it in there sim I hated it yeah
when you I mean people yeah what does
that even mean yeah like you know that
the song is like platinum yeah yeah what
yeah I don't know I guarantee everyone
listen to the song up until they heard
you say fortnight literally everyone
turned the song off that's how upset
they were 100% yeah Hunter first o'deary
yeah those dreams were like up into that
yeah yeah that's one thing that's so
funny about like rap and [ __ ] as people
are so like yeah like I'm just like man
this I was broke like II feel like I was
yeah bro like I'm having fun I'm
enjoying myself and there's a time I
play I just did a song the other day
called not right now it's pretty dope
it's like it's about uh where's my phone
I can give you a little sample and it's
dope it's big boner dot-com tune in for
your morning just a song a day called
morning game boner yeah so this is this
is about I was writing it because I've
been working on an album right now which
is a sequel to my first album called
under pressure okay and it's like talks
about a lot of really dope [ __ ] on it
like it's very hip-hop very dope but not
like not like I have an album called
young Sinatra for it which is kind of
boom bap hip hop this one is more modern
hip I don't know how to explain it but
anyway but I'm talking about a lot of
[ __ ] I'm talking about my life and the
things I've gone through and having a
child and all types of stuff and you're
having a child yeah I'm having a little
boy Oh congrats thank you very much holy
[ __ ]
little Bobby just Bobby dropping us a
little bit you guys get that yeah cuz
you're cool thank you thank you bro but
I was like in my head I was like alright
it's not a big deal like it it's good to
have fun bro like now I don't need to be
the lyrical miracle spiritual habitual
ritual guy all the time and that's why I
do songs like I have this these mixtapes
called um Bobby Tarantino yeah you could
have people who hate on that [ __ ] but I
do it because it's like I don't
blow my [ __ ] brains out talking about
the realist most sensitive most like
insanely emotional with the world is
mass shootings every day everyone's what
the [ __ ] like I just want to [ __ ]
turn up so I did this one song that was
kind of meets it in the middle and this
is just a little fun like it's like it's
like kind of turned out but I'm also
glad to say something
we have forever done this where we a
video or a song or something and we
played into the mic and the fact that
you're doing it it's great it's great
it's a full circle that is perfectly
yeah
this is a great morning Boni let it rip
morning boner well premiere oh wait this
is working no yes no it's not working
goddamn it's fine I'm connected to my
crib
oh I'm just connected to my entire house
hey what am i bad I just connected to
the whole house okay here we go yes I
like this year this is turnt Oh Felicity
lyrics
[Music]
no actually killing him back to the
murder and back to the place where you
don't agree with they all agree with the
name wonderful morning boner morning
throwing the world premiere boner boner
drop just dropped those crazy laughter
though
[Music]
anyway so that's like wow like this six
produce' six did produce that oh yeah
he's great not just six that homework
you've done yeah but yet so I sorry go
ahead
no it's cool I was just talking about
mourning boomers oh yeah I was gonna say
I too so like one of the only podcast I
wasn't do is how I built this yeah and
your episode came up I was [ __ ]
fascinated thank you the story it's a
great story yeah it's pretty it's it's
quite wild I loved it I loved it just
kind of the way that everything's played
out it's made me really appreciate where
I am now yeah it was dope yes cool who's
your who's your manager Chris aru okay
is he still the same guy that yes that
horse teeth [ __ ] yeah no but
that's my dude yeah he found me on
Twitter randomly he's like you know
click this link and saw me just rapping
walking down the street and I was living
in a big Lenny's basement that's my
homie and now he's my artist who I
signed him learn he was land surveying
for 12 years where he would like measure
the property line of you know houses and
different buildings and stuff like that
and then we just became friends and he
let me live in it live in his basement
like I said and Chris discovered me and
then we just started grinding and
putting up mixtapes and before I knew it
me and Lenny we were on our way I told
him to quit his job and we moved to LA
and that's crazy yeah it's it was it's
actually a lot more [ __ ] that would
enter it in that sounds like go pretty
easy
yeah pretty easy couple months okay no
problem nice everyone listen to this
like I have lived in a basement that's
not that hard I can live in a basement
play video games in abyss yeah every
gamer like I have a morning game boner
my mom's basement right now the [ __ ] is
special about this guy waiting game
boner
maybe yeah yeah an MGB morning game
boring game boner yeah need to like
write commercials for like Steam and
like Xbox
like hot girls being like do you have
morning game bum yeah let's help you
release it yeah
sayonara PLAs my girlf it's like ooh
someone's horny i'm horny for [ __ ]
games but nor a crowd still up you know
whacking it to those ps1 to these yeah
girl you already know it is as soon as
you consent 2019 about that something
the dotted line yeah oh that would be
really I know you guys do this [ __ ] like
that I haven't heard one yet yes okay
here is the yeah yes you one
definitely yeah [ __ ] it let's do right
now definitely it was do track all
morning game boner will put it out on
Soundcloud will make like some [ __ ] a
rap supergroup that doesn't exist
mmm-hmm we'll just put a list of members
that aren't real like 30 people in there
yeah Kanye yeah but we got to change
everybody's name it's got to be like
sexual innuendos yeah totally Kanye
breasts yeah
Oh a lodge dick Mac so cranes Lodge dick
yeah logic logic Mac so cream nice Oh
creams it's like porn star names bode
buck naked uh no come Cody come yeah
Cody cow yeah Noel driller and a well
drills
[Music]